can you throw comedy punch yeah all the
time okay would you give them that you
have no job pretty he's up for this you
know how hard you have to punch him talk
so you're asking me to pan no not really
an expensive Hollywood no don't break
our Hollywood star breaking then you
mean punch him like a punch Jennifer
yeah yeah okay well then you have to
come and stand over here okay do you
know know you're doing this and it's
you're gonna feel the wind okay
pass your face okay and I just heard you
say that sly is mischievous yes I'm not
mischievous okay so you go straight to
the point
I'm a killer okay this doesn't work I'd
bite your knees don't anticipate okay
I'm kind of come close all right let me
just measure
let me just match them
[Applause]
beautiful daughter
[Music]
you